اعلنت الولايات المتحده عن قاذفه بي 21
الاولى من الجيل السادس من الطائرات لكن
لماذا تصنف بالجيل السادس وما هي المميزات
في هذا الجيل المختلفه عن سابقتها
[موسيقى]
الجيل الاول من الطائرات استخدم المحرك
النفاث
[موسيقى]
في الجيل الثاني ظهرت الاجنحه المرتده
للخلف والرادق
في الجيل الثالث الطائرات المخترقه لحاجز
الصوت
الرابع امتلك قدره عاليه على المناوره
وبصمه الرادريه منخفضه
اما الجيل الخامس فامتلك خاصيه الشبح
قبل ان نتجه للسادس دعونا نشرح ماذا نعني
بخاصيه الشبح وكيف تقاس
هكذا يبدو لنا حجم الطائره القاذفه من
طراز بي 52
مقارنه بطائره اف 16
لكن هاتين الطائرتين لا تبدوان كذلك
بالنسبه للرادار
للحصول على ميزه الشبح تصمم الطائرات بشكل
هندسي وباستخدام مواده في الهيكل تمنع
انعكاس اشعه الرادار
هذا ما يسمى بالمقطع الراداري العرضي هو
ما يراه الرادار من الطائره يقاس بالمتر
المربع
طائره b52 يقدر حجمها على الرادار بمائه
متر مربع في حين تمتلك طائره اف 16
مقطعا راداريا بمساحه اربعه امتار مربعه
اي ان بصمتها الرادريه منخفضه
لكن طائرات الشبح تمتلك اقل من ذلك بكثير
طائره اف 35 يقدر ما يراه الرادار بانه
بحجم كره الجولف اما بالنسبه للطائره
بواحد وعشرين فالمقطع العرضي للرادار تشير
التقديرات الى انه بحجم النحله او ربما
بحجم البعوضه هذا ما ستحتاج انظمه رادار
الدفاع الجوي لالتقاقه لكن ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبه لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
كلما صغر المقطع العظمي للرادار كلما اصبح
تتبع الطائره اصعب وقلت المسافه التي يمكن
لرادار الدفاع الجوي اكتشاف الطائره منها
حتى يصبح الوضع متاخرا جدا لاعتراض
الطائره فحينها تكون الطائره اكتشفت
المنظومه واستهدفتها قبلها بكثير
لكن كل هذه المميزات الشبحيه هي للجيل
الخامس من الطائرات اما مميزات الجيل
السادس فتسمح بنقل المعلومات من الطائره
الى بقيه القطاع العسكريه وتكوين شبكه
معلومات على ارض المعارك اي ان الطائره
ستعمل كقائدا او نقطه اتصال تعطي
المعلومات للقطع البريه والبحريه والجويه
كافه
وتتواصل معها الاقمار الصناعيه
كما ستساعد الطيارين بالتركيز على
العمليات القتاليه لان الذكاء الصناعي
سيتولى الكثير من المهام فيها